okay  zurich again oh maybe now i play okay  one king crab just won this tournament  yeah google king crab time  oh and i deserved oh free queen oh the  king crap pays off  i won the queen in the first 10 moves  wow  the strong opening it was it was so nice  to switch the king and the queen  because now the queen is aggressively  placed  yeah don't mess with the king crab  what a fun opening that was so much fun  i kind of regret not playing bishop e2  king here here  here here here and then mate  but wow  yeah so the whole so the whole idea with  this opening  was to have the queen access the side  and then to prepare this  and the pieces work together very nicely  and  yeah the idea of knife b5 was uh  was supported by a4 so it was very very  long-term  strategy but yeah probably never again  i'm playing that